all right
so hi everyone um as you said my name is
pascal and
um so i've spent the last few months
uh reading the angular 2 source code
and today i would like to share some
some learnings
uh with you um and uh especially about
dependency injection for
future generations so i took the topic
dependency injection because
um because of a couple of reasons i
think that
dependency injection is important or at
least it's a nice pattern to to write
better
code and in addition to that i think
that the angular team has
done a very very good job on the new
dependency injection system
um before i start a couple of things so
first i want to
thank two persons um merrick christensen
from
salt lake city he gave a great talk on
dependency injection at angie vegas
just a few weeks ago and he basically
allowed me to steal some ideas for my
talk
and then there's also voyagina who's a
former
core member of the angular team and he
gave a talk about the new dependency
injection system
last year at ngconf which is what
everything in this talk is basically
based on he made the original version
what you see today will be like the
latest and greatest and i hope you like
it
um right and then there's another thing
uh it has nothing to do with the talk at
all but i think it's
it's fun to share so just recently um
i bought some some new sunglasses and
a soap bubble gun and a selfie stick
and so you might you might ask yourself
so why is this
guy telling us about his latest
achievements and online shopping
so the reason for that is that um it
didn't take long for me to realize that
you can do some very very fun
stuff with it and this is what i what i
did
so basically it's me running around
randomly in the office
with my selfie stick and shooting with
soap bubbles as
my colleagues um but yeah let's
let's talk some business
all right so dependency injection um
so i talked with some people here at the
conference and and so they came to me
and they asked me yeah so you're
you're giving a talk here right and i
was like yeah and they were like okay so
what are you talking about i was like
yeah dependency injection
and they're like okay so so what are you
talking about then so
there's not so much to say about it and
uh it turned out that
in fact about dependency injection
itself there's not
super much to to tell about but um
again there will be much more especially
in terms of the angular 2 dependency
injection system
so nonetheless um here is my talk
basically in a single slide
uh dependency injection is a 25 term
for five cent concept and that's uh
sort of true actually um
so this guy right here this is voita i'm
one of the ones that i've mentioned
at the beginning of the talk and um this
is uh
where he gave his talk at ngconf about
dependency injection
and so he said that
we can see dependency injection
basically as
first as a design pattern and we can
also see it as a framework and we have
to distinguish between those two things
and this is um what i would like to do
today as well i would like to
show you the the pattern itself so that
you that you that we all know what
dependency injection actually is
the the five cent concept and then we
talk about the
the dependency injection system or the
framework
so di as a design pattern or also known
as the five cent concept
let's start with this class right here
so this is an es6 class
it's a car and it has a constructor and
there's some stuff going on it has a
method drive to actually drive
and in the constructor we can see that
there are basically three dependencies
right we have
we have an engine we have tires and we
have doors
in order to to create our uh car
and um so despite the fact that we now
have
three different ways to create objects
at the
particular point um turns out that this
is actually
not a good thing to do it like that we
have some problems with that code
and the problems the problem that we
have is that
so the car itself knows how to create an
engine
and the car itself knows how to get
tires and doors
and this can be a problem if you want to
test your code and as we all know
we love testing and we just do it every
day
we want to be able to to write tests
for this particular class without uh too
much effort like just
just think about uh switching or
swapping out those dependencies
with mocks right it's pretty hard to do
um so what we need is
a way to kind of abstract those
implementation details away
so that the car doesn't know about it
right and this is what it looks like
so basically what we do is we we pass in
the
the uh dependencies that we have in the
constructor
so now the car needs an engine it needs
tires and it needs doors in order to
to be created and this makes the code
much more testable
right because now when we create a
car we are able to inject our
dependencies from the outside world and
the car itself
doesn't know how to create those objects
um and this is especially important when
we run tests
um for each test we want to create a
different environment right
like when you write a test spec um you
have different
scenarios that you want to represent in
your spec and therefore you need to be
able to um create objects in in
different
um scenarios and in certain
circumstances
so in the end you can say that
testing and reusable code is somewhat
like the same
thing right and uh this kind of
uh construction that we see here is also
called constructor
injection and what we can do now is we
can create our car like this
right we pass in our three dependencies
and if we write a test
we can do it like that and uh yay
our code is now testable which is cool
and basically um that's it that's
dependency injection
okay um there's another problem though
that we have now
which is this guy here we now have a uh
main method we now have to kind of wire
all of our dependencies together
manually ourselves in order to create a
car
object right so here we see all
dependencies
and then we get our car so in this case
it's just a very very small application
but just just imagine you have like a
lot of classes and
and components and whatever um
this can get very very hairy just think
about um
adding just another dependency right
so you have to really maintain it on
each and every single object
so wouldn't it be nice
if we uh have a
if we had a um system for that or a kind
of service that takes care of wiring
everything together
when we ask for a specific object and
and this is basically
where um dependency injection as a
framework comes in
so first we just talked about the design
pattern itself
but now we want to we need a solution
that makes the maintainability um
actually
good so getting back to our main method
what we want to do or what would be very
nice if is
if we could do something something like
this so
we create an ejector wherever it
comes from it's just a very abstract
kind of code
and we asked the injector to get a car
like an instance of car
and then we could use the car in order
to work with that
now the injector knows how to create a
car
and if the car has dependencies then the
injector also takes care of
instantiating those dependencies
otherwise the car cannot be created
but you see that all the wiring is not
there anymore the injector takes care of
that
so it turns out that in angular 1 for
example we have
that kind of system already so here we
have our car class
and in order to tell the injector what
other dependencies are needed in order
to create such an object
we have to annotate our code and this is
where the dollar inject property of a
class comes in
right this is one way of annotating our
code in angular 1 in order to tell the
injector hey
if you create an object of this class or
this service
you also need to create dependencies or
other objects from from those classes
so and once we've done that we could do
something like this
so what we see here is a uh an angular
module that is created
and we register our car as a car service
so basically what happens here is we say
okay when somebody asks for car
uh that um person gets a uh an instance
of the car service
so and then we have another service that
actually asks for car
and what you see here is another way of
um
asking for an object
without actually annotating the service
itself
so here angular actually
finds out or smart enough to find out
what what dependency you actually need
based on the parameter name which is car
and that
in that case which of course is a
problem when you minify your code
um and then in that case you want to use
some kind of annotation
like like dollar inject okay
this is all cool um the the dependency
injection system works very well but
there we still have some some problems
so first we have an internal cache
uh in the injector so whenever we get an
object
from a specific service it's always a
singleton
so if you ask for a car service then you
get an instance of car service
and if you ask for car service at
another place
you get the same the exact same instance
back
which is something we probably don't
want maybe we want to
get a different instance whenever we ask
for a specific object
another problem is that this uh
dependency injection system is
synchronous by default so we're not able
to inject
dependencies that are asynchronously
resolved
and we have namespace collisions there
is no
things like that there's nothing like
like a real namespace system so when you
create a service
with a name car and there's a
third-party extension
angular extension that also introduces a
service car then the last one wins right
it basically overrides your service so
it's not really able to
[Music]
have two different services
with the same token and one application
right and then last but not least
it's built right into the framework the
di system of angular 1 is not a system
that we can use in any other code if you
write react or amber or whatever
there's nothing you can do you either
you either take the whole framework or
or nothing
which brings us to the next animated gif
taking di to the next level
is anybody into dragon ball i really
like that one
okay so di and angular 2
[Music]
before we take a look at code of the new
di system
let's first understand the concept of
the new dei system so
in angular 2 um the dependency injection
system
has of course an injector right
this is something that we want to have
we want to have a service that we can
ask for
for object creation and then of course
what an injector does
is it creates an object this is what
dependency injection in the end is all
about
object creation so
now the big question is how do we get
there
like how does the the injector know
how to instantiate a particular
um object when we ask for a service how
does how does the injector know how to
create that object
in angular 1 we have things like dot
service dot factory dot value dot
whatever
in angular 2 and the dependency
injection system we get something that
is called
a binding so a binding
is basically an instruction that tells
the inductor
how to create an object of a certain
token
right so you can see a binding
as a sort of recipe how to create an
object
and it takes a token whatever token is
we'll get to that in a second
and based on that token it creates or
the the injector creates that object but
the the binding instruction knows
how to create an object of a certain
dependency
based on a token
okay so so what does that actually look
like in code
this is what it looks like in code so
what you see here is
we are injecting a class injector from
the angular di source code
and this might change in the future so
don't spend too much energy on the first
line it's just
somewhere of some way of getting that
particular class
and then we're creating an injector with
the method
resolve and create and resolve and
create is basically a sort of
factory function that lets us create
injector instances
like different injector services that we
need
and the resolve and create function gets
a list of bindings so you see that
that this list here is basically just a
list of the classes that we need as
dependencies so you might wonder
how can classes just be like real
bindings because they're just classes
right
we we get into that in a minute what we
want to focus on now is
how does the injector know
um how to create a car when we ask for a
car
and if the car has dependencies how does
the injector know which dependencies
actually to resolve
of course we're passing on all the
dependencies in our factory function
right here that we need in our entire
application
but it doesn't tell the the uh injector
um which dependencies are needed for
this particular
car service so if we take a look at our
car class
it's exactly the same code we again need
something like annotation
our class needs to know what
dependencies are needed in order to
create an object of it
and this is where this comes in
so what we do here we again we inject
something
from the uh di system it's called
inject and then we extend the current
constructor with those weird guys here
and you might wonder
what the hell is that so
basically what happens here is
it's a metadata information that tells
the injector that the first parameter of
that constructor is an
instance of the type engine and the
second one is tires and the third one is
doors
and the type here is actually also a
token at the same time
but how is it possible that we can use
inject with this add sign
so what you see here is something that
is called decorators
and decorators is a proposal for es7 so
it's really like something that
eventually will be standardized and
decorators allow us to like the name
says
um to to decorate existing objects with
additional information
and um the reason that we are
able to to write the code like this and
make it run is only because we
we can use transpilers today right so
there are two transpilers that actually
um support decorators and those are
babel and um typescript
so in a decorator in the end is just a
function
right the the at sign that we use is
just uh
part of the syntax but in the end the
decorator itself is just
just a function so what we see here is a
very very simplified implementation of
what the inject decorator does
it takes some dependencies and it has
access to the target
which in our case is the car class and
then it adds some parameters
on that class that's all it does so
basically what happens is we call inject
with engine
on the car instance or on the car class
so what that means is
if we take a look at that code and we
transpire that to es5
what we get is something like that right
a class in es6 in the end it's just a
function es5
and parameters is just a property on
that particular function
and then we have an area of parameters
and you see that each parameter
currently is also
an area itself that's just because if
you have
more than one annotation or decorate uh
decorator
for a single parameter those are listed
up in each array
so in the end what this decorator does
it really just
adds metadata to that particular class
and the injection system is able to read
out that data in order to
find out which other dependencies need
to be instantiated
in order to create a car object does
that make sense
okay everybody goes like like this so we
can move on
so but let's get back to the bindings
what is happening here so we just pass
in a list of classes
and those are supposed to be bindings so
it turns out that
those classes here as we write them
there is actually
it's part of a kind of shorthand syntax
it's like an implicit syntax of defining
bindings
we can write the explicit version of it
and it would be
it would look something like this
so we import a function bind
from the di system and and then this is
what happens we say okay we create an
injector with the following bindings
we bind the token car to the class car
and we do the same for the for the
engine for the tires and for the doors
so basically what we're seeing here what
we're passing to bind is a token and a
token can be a type which in the end is
a class
or a string and we bind it to another
class
and the classes are here so you might
wonder why why do we want to do that
actually
this is something you probably won't do
because you can just use the the
shorthand syntax
but what this allows us to do is
something like this
bind engine to class other engine boom
so i show once again
we bind the token engine to another
class
other engine what does that mean
so it enables us basically to do three
things
first we uh we are able to
map a token that is used across our
application to
any class doesn't matter so if you have
a
if you have an application with 10
classes and they all ask for something
like
engine they will get an instance of
other engine
if you want to swap out that dependency
you can just do it there you just bind
it to another class
and there are no name conflicts anymore
because other engine in that case is
also just
a type or a class or maybe just another
variable that is
uh that has the value of another class
so if you're using um
or yeah if you're using a dependency
that is called
engine and you have a third-party uh
library or extension that also
introduces a service engine
then this is the way how you can
actually map both
[Music]
both dependencies into your application
without any name collision
right and this is actually
not all we can we can do more so there
are more binding instructions
next to two class we also have something
like two value
which actually lets us bind a token to
some value
so what happens here is we bind string
to the to the string hello world
so if you have a class that has a
dependency of type string
what you get is hello world as a string
which is
amazing because uh you can do something
like configuration
configurations with that that are
injectable
we have uh two les which basically
maps a token to yet another token
right so if you have an engine and you
would rather name it a v8
for whatever reason you can create an
alias for that particular token that
binds to a class engine
which is super powerful and of course we
have factories
so in some cases you might need
something like that where you have a
function that actually
finds out which dependency you're
actually
uh you actually want to instantiate so
whenever somebody asks for
um an object that is of type engine
what you get back is either an v8 engine
or
v6 engine depending on what the
condition
evaluates to and of course the factory
itself can
can have their own dependencies which is
um
so so you can introduce them just with a
second parameter here
it's just a list of another another list
of tokens that your injectors already
configured
and then you can use those in your
factory
and i think this is actually pretty
pretty cool because it's like super
powerful it basically solves all
problems that we have for the di system
in angular 1 right now
so there's still one thing that we
haven't talked about yet which is
asynchronicity
so what are we doing with that
it turns out that the udi system
introduces yet another binding
instruction
which is called two async factory
and what two async factory allows us to
do is basically
we can create a promise and the promise
will eventually
resolve or reject depending on whatever
happens inside that
code and then it will return that
promise and whenever we ask for
something like engine in that case we
get an engine promise
which eventually will be resolved so
here
we return a promise we fetch some engine
data
and when the data comes back we actually
create a new instance of engine
with that data right but still
in your in your application code you
just
ask for something of type engine
this leads to more um decorators
because all of a sudden we have two
strategies we can inject
um dependency synchronous uh synchronous
or asynchronous
which means we need a new decorator that
tells
our application or our injector
that some parameters are actually
injected
asynchronously so what we can do
is we use inject promise
as a decorator so what it does is it
basically um tests the
the injector okay so this is the token
engine
and um and the injection system then
finds out okay so it's it's
the the token that is bound to the async
factory so it returns a promise
so what we get is an engine promise and
then later in our constructor we can use
that promise
in order to react on some some stuff
depending on what the
what the promise does there's another
thing called
inject lazy and inject lazy basically
gives you the factory function
that the ejector itself uses in order to
create
um a dependency so in this case you can
create an engine only if you really need
it
and we also have optional dependencies
so a decorator optional and this is uh
by the way the first time you see
more than one decorator and one
parameter and um so what happens here is
we're injecting an engine which is
optional and if there is no engine in
the system then it will return now
it can be uh very helpful if you have
something like
um that your let's say your your your
class expect something like jquery or
something
and it's just optional then it allows
you to um create a fallback
or ask for a fallback so
the following problems are not solved in
this di system which are
so we have asynchronous and synchronous
uh strategies
we have no namespace conflicts anymore
through the
because of the the binding instructions
it can be used standalone whatever you
see right here is a
framework agnostic system right i
actually saw people using that with
react
which i think is awesome
but there's still one thing dependencies
are served as singletons
so it turns out that the new di system
still returns
singletons so how do we handle that
there's a concept that is called
transient dependencies
and what that means is we can we can
create
child injectors in our application in
order to override some bindings
or in order to get different uh
instances of a specific class
so what does it look like here we have
the same code
we create an injector with a binding
engine which is
as we know a bind engine two class
engine
and we create a child injector that gets
the same
binding but if we ask both both
injectors for that
um type we get different instances
right so this is one thing
the other thing is that
if we like when we create a child
injector and we have a parent injector
that
uh has more than just an engine binding
and we ask the child injector for a
binding that is actually not configured
in the
child injector then those bindings are
locked up in the in the parent injector
it sounds super confusing that's why i
have this awesome
graphic here that i by the way stole
from from merrick
so we create a parent injector with
three bindings
with four bindings car engine and tires
and doors
and we create a child injector with car
and engine
and we create another child injector
with just car
so what happens if we now ask the second
child injector
for a service car what we get is
the car object created by the child
child
injector but there's no engine binding
configured in that child injector so it
looks it up in the parent injector and
so on and so forth so it's a kind of
prototypical inheritance what's
happening here
you're not impressed so
when i saw that the first time i was
like like wow that's
awesome and super flexible and
everything
but yeah so how is it used in angular 2
then
so i don't know if you've seen any
angular 2 code yet
you probably did this is what a
component angular 2 looks like
so we have a class in this case just has
a constructor that sets the name
property and nothing nothing special
here
and then we have two more decorators
also known as annotations
um and the component decorator basically
tells angular hey this particular class
is a component
and the view annotation tells angular
this
view configuration is the view for this
component
nothing super special about it and then
we just need to bootstrap that
application bootstrap is a function that
we also need to import from the angular
source code
from from the framework so this is how
you create your first angular 2
application
super simple so what happens if we want
to inject a service
so we create a service name service it
does nothing special
it sets the name property and it has a
method to get the name
and what we do then is we pass that
service
to that bootstrap function and this is
basically the resolve and create part
right so you pass on a binding what
you're allowed to do is you can also use
the bind syntax here
so it's again just the shorthand syntax
in order to make the name service
available across your entire application
and then in your component what you need
to do is
you just inject that name service
of the type name service and get an
instance of that
if you're into typescript you can just
use typescript like that
so you add type annotations
and it works the same way what is
interesting here is you don't have
any decorator machinery here anymore
right so this is just plain typescript
code
and it works out of the box
there's another thing um you might want
to
use child injectors in order to uh
create a different binding for a name
service in a particular component and
this is where the
injectables property of the component
comes in
so if you've seen that what it basically
does is it
uh just configures new bindings for that
particular component it's basically a
child
injector that is created at that point
okay so so we learned that the
di system the new di system in angular 2
solves all the problem of
angular 1. and it's super flexible
it is synchronous and asynchronous and
you can use it with your code because
it's framework agnostic which is awesome
and
that's all i have thank you very much
[Applause]
well there are a lot of questions so
we're going to be sitting here for a
while i know coffee for you
uh-oh uh-oh please please ask questions
that i can actually answer
thank you there are only hard questions
i don't know
how we are going to manage okay so the
first one is can you explain the
difference between the dependency
injection pattern
and the factory pattern the dependency
injection pattern and the factory
pattern
[Music]
in angular 1 or is it the question from
twitter
yes okay then it's probably a bit hard
to ask so
the factory pattern as a design pattern
itself it's it's just a pattern that
creates an instance of an object
but it has nothing to do with with
dependency injection per se it's just a
way of
creating objects so what you can do is
instead of
doing something like var car equals new
car
so you're asking the you're calling the
constructor directly what you can do is
you can have a car factory
that gives you a car um so you basically
abstract the concrete implementation
away
which is good but it has nothing to do
with dependency injections so it's
not really a versus our question i guess
so the next one is pretty great if you
should convince people about
static typing in javascript what would
you say
you can do it in dramatic voice
so i like typescript that's my answer
fair enough i think that's acceptable um
can you explain the benefits of the da
framework over a more traditional
amd loading approach okay
so that's a good question um
i think i think we need to distinguish
here amd
is a module system that allows you to to
load modules
in an es5 today right you can do it with
with common js or system.js or amd or
whatever you want to do
um dependency injection is on a
different layer
it doesn't um solve the problem of
loading modules right so what you've
seen in the code was
um we used es6 and es6 modules
um but the dependency injection
basically has nothing to do with it so
there are two different things
loading modules and dependency injection
okay two more which are kind of
connected
how async dependency injection works
after minification
and will async dependencies allow
generators as well
that's a good question so the the
minification
actually is decoupled from whatever
binding instruction you use so the nice
thing that we have with the new
dependency injection system
is we we can use string tokens but we
don't have to
so if you just do something like bind
car to class car
there's no string and minification just
works right and you cannot
minify strings so that's actually better
um
i'm actually not sure how the generator
support will be in the asynchronous
device
there are just so many questions i think
we're going to sit here forever
seriously
well we have a couple more minutes so
might as well um
can we inject objects into functions
instead of class constructors
oh good question um again a class is
just a function
so if you transpile a class in es6 to
es5
it will be just a constructor function
so the answer is yes in the end you can
use that system in es5
and just write functions it's the same
the same stuff it's
just that um that one slide where we saw
what the decorator does to that class
when we transpile it
so the answer is yes for the rest of the
conference we're just going to have this
interview basically just bring food okay
and coffee thank you
um okay two more because i guess they
will be quick is there a way to destroy
cleanup injectors to what sorry is there
a way to destroy
slash cleanup injectors ah okay um
no i mean it's just an object so
same would apply to the injector as to
every object in javascript
okay last question um how can we handle
code modification do we have
do we have an inject variable in angular
2 as well
right so i think that question i already
answered with the other answers that's
what i thought
right so sure minification just works
it's just code um
if you don't use strings then it's even
better and you can use that do that with
the new dependency injection system
so yeah okay maybe one question for the
audience
if there is one or everyone was using
twitter
i i have a question actually to yourself
okay
no to you guys um are you actually
excited about that stuff i was super
excited when i learned about it but you
were like
[Applause]
hello in the returning about
where ah over there here hi there here
in return in about asynchronous md
common gs they are solved the same
problem as
the dependency also and the
models loading loading models why we
should use something else
if we have common gear that solves the
same problem
so i'm i think it's it's not really this
exactly the same
problem like when you use something like
amd or common js it's
still just a way to load a module or to
load a dependency but you still at some
point have a sort of
main function that you need to maintain
in order to
create objects it of course it depends
on your on your code and on your use
case
but um as i said so so you have module
loading which is one thing
and you have dependency injection which
is which is really just
a way of creating objects and then
passing them
into constructors which you maybe want
to abstract away what you can do with
that
system so i i think those are two
different things
that's my opinion at least okay
okay since we could actually sit here
forever from
what i'm saying like hand wise and
twitter wise
and i think everyone wants coffee and
also
we have another talk up coming after the
break
we're going to break it off but worry
not pascal's still here
you can catch him and ask all the
questions he might
get or not get annoying i also have
stickers by the way
yeah interesting stickers uh so if you
have any more questions for rascal
as i'm sure you do just catch them
during the break or during lunch but
let the guy eat first please thank you
so much that was amazing
thank you very much
you